michael pittman jr on his way to the nfl
with 101 receptions 1275 yards and 11
touchdowns in his final year at usc
michael pittman jr joins us now michael
how are you buddy good good how are you
we're doing great what's up big homie i
mean does your dad still say that
because that was his thing like oh what
up what up big homie that's how he
always used to call me nah i mean he's
never said that to me no he never said
that well you're a son yeah i guess
you're not really the homie category
what happened to your arms though i mean
they're still decent size they're decent
i mean but they're not as big as his
is our dad's arm still like they were
when he played uh they're not as big but
like but like yeah like they're still
they're still large there's no way he
gave that up yeah that was such a
special attribute how old were you when
you realized you'd have a chance if if
if stuff went down with dad how old were
you
i'd say me and my brother
thought we could take our dad when i hit
probably like 18. how's that together
[Laughter]
that's running back strength you only
got wide receiver strength he's on
another level no in all seriousness
though your your dad is one of my
favorite teammates ever he was always
great to me he believed in me even when
times were a little hard and i i told
people and i know this interview is
supposed to be about you but one of my
biggest kicks used to be on friday we
had him and thomas jones do you know
thomas jones the running back no look
him up after this because he was jacked
like your dad okay and they used to go
in there and do like arms on a friday it
was like oh my gosh it was a
bodybuilding competition it was um and
then they have their sleeves rolled up
and practiced showing it all so it was
pretty cool did you want to be a running
back until you developed into not
running back body yeah so i actually
played running back until my junior year
because i just got tall so and then like
i was like six two and like i started to
outgrow that and then i like
transitioned to being a wideout
how uh what's this been like so far i
mean does dad give you
yeah what to expect yeah nice yeah so i
haven't talked to him like since i've
been here but um
like just like before this uh just
telling me like what to expect and
everything that like should happen and
uh just like don't get flustered just
stay calm and just um be you yeah yeah
you are you um what happened for you
from 2018 to 2019. i'm looking at 41
catches 2018 and boom up to a 101 60
more catches in 2019. yeah um they just
asked me to take a bigger role and i've
always wanted that role and uh one thing
led to another and we had some good um
quarterback play the
offense like had some spark to it and uh
we started making more plays yeah i mean
and they threw the ball they threw the
hell out of it they threw it almost
every play it seemed like not every
player no but a lot we did a lot a lot
yeah you definitely did um all right so
i mean you're a pro i saw you in action
this year when usc came to notre dame
you got great size you're tough as hell
you block you do it all like give me the
one thing that you want to improve on
your game going into your rookie year
yeah so um i feel like i do a good job
of getting out of routes but like
getting into routes uh and like just um
fixing that so like you can get in and
out to us yeah so so like you can get
into your routes faster and it'll make
the top of your route look that much
faster and happen that much faster and
and and like it'll help you get back to
the ball quicker is that things like
dropping hips as you're about to take a
break or dropping hips and just like
getting your head and hips turned
quicker and just staying low and being
like more like controlled yeah so
instead of relying so much on your size
and language you've been you know
exactly you've done throughout your
career which is what you should do all
right all anybody cares about is how
fast guys can run into straight line for
40 yards what's your target for the 40.
uh my target i think that we'll have to
find out when it comes time for a 40 day
setting no expectations no expectations
at all well are you going to do the
whole workout here as far as you are
you're doing everything you are okay and
then you know all right so you got some
goals as far as what you're going to hit
you're nervous about the 40. i could
tell nervous no because it's
nerve-racking he just wanted to tell us
he didn't tell us
it is but at the same time like i've
been running fast like my whole life
yeah i'm just gonna get out there and
try to run fast right no i'm i'm gonna
tell you it's the weirdest thing ever
and i mean that in a good way but i
literally was running down the track at
the combine like going i'm running at
the combine i'm running it the combine i
really was thinking no you do that every
year here i do well we played it
yesterday
yeah but all right that's cool um you
know
it's a stacked wide receiver's class
yeah absolutely i mean it's stacked you
got this one baller after another
give me who's a guy that you watched on
in college football the last year or two
that jumps out to you at the position
that you like their game yeah well um
just like any position no i like those
receivers yeah yeah well i mean i think
it'd be like judy and lamb yeah doesn't
it too i mean like those have been the
guys like since like day one uh watching
them as like young guys and uh turning
on the bama games oklahoma games and
just like watching them make crazy plays
so those are two really good guys i mean
but like
but like let's say like everybody here
is really good yeah right or else they
wouldn't be here sure sure what have you
done to prepare for the meetings with
the teams we here every year after the
combine some crazy questions they you
know they try to get you off of your
preparation
and and kind of draw out what's really
underneath it what have you done to
prepare yourself for what's coming um
i'm just being myself and uh having fun
really
you just want to talk slow and don't get
talking fast because then that's when
they get you so just kind of stay calm
and relax and just be up front honest
and then everything goes
uh and like everything goes right so
who's um
the last two years who's the best player
you've seen in college football or one
against the best player guy
i'd say
leviska is up there
aj espensa from um iowa
right um
uh jaylen johnson
from utah i mean like there's a bunch of
good players oh yeah so yeah probably
like one of those one of those three
yeah yeah okay who's the guy when you
get to the nfl you're going to look
across and you're going to say i can't
believe i'm on the same field as this
guy probably tyrant matthews or patrick
peterson oh okay yeah tyrone matthews
gonna put you in your place man he's
gonna put you in he's gonna show you the
honey badger hey he may be teammates i
love having fun because i feel like i
can i feel like his dad won't get mad at
me can you imagine a six four receiver
on the chiefs they got all those fast
guys you got to balance it out with a
big guy red zone threat compliment
travis kelsey you may be seeing him in
practice not in games yeah i mean maybe
i mean anything is possible
anything is possible and you would take
catching balls from patrick mahomes i'm
sure no doubt about it all right well
michael we appreciate some of your time
congratulations on your success it's
great to have another michael pittman in
the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports